are you guys doing great how are you
doing I'm doing excellent I have about
18 questions and four minutes go oh here
we go the most popular genre on the
planet is the superhero genre what is it
about the comic book movies in the super
hashanah right now that it has so many
people are so excited to see them I mean
I think it's the wish fulfillment and
that's why I love Shazam so much because
it's kind of the ultimate wish
fulfillment for this kid getting to
actually be a superhero and I think that
each of you know it's really about the
great characters they populate a lot of
the superhero movies and each superhero
movie is different than the other
superhero movies it's a large yawn
rebutted you have heist movies you have
comedies you have you know two pure
action and so I think there's a lot of
room one of the things that really
impressed me was the boardroom scene and
what you guys were able to get away with
in that scene because it shows that this
guy is mark Strong's character is a
force to be reckoned with
was there any debate on showing what he
got away with I don't want to be
specific but I mean to me it was always
yeah it was that balance of you know you
don't want to go too far because it's
not a horror movie you know but you
still want to have that real threat so
you actually feel that okay this could
actually go bad for our heroes but to me
it was just you know you can be scary
without blood and gore and then to just
still set up a real threat we knew we
needed a real sense of Jeopardy so that
when the kids ultimately faced off
against sivanna we knew as an audience
that there was a real potential for
danger I'm this is a massive question
completely spoiler free I loved the
ending and I'm curious when did you guys
know that was going to be the ending and
I'm going to start with that which
ending the I want to say stuff that
happens in the carnival that maybe the
audience is not expecting I mean that
was always the plan because it's such a
great payoff to
you know the characters and the story
that we're setting up so yeah that was
always part of the plan so that was
ground-floor when you're making this
movie you're like this is gonna happen
yeah what's interesting is it's managed
to be under wraps again I'm talking in
very vague terms but it managed to be
under wraps this whole time how hard has
it been to keep all this without leaking
we hope that people will continue to
keep it under wraps because it's such a
satisfying reveal so I hope that people
are gonna you know stay with us for the
next three weeks until the movie comes
out you know without without having to
be spoiled it's great and it's been hard
it's been hard but you know we're
delight that most people see the upside
of keeping it secret because it just
works so well when did winning catch you
by surprise
completely I listen I love the movie
I've said this again and again I think
it's gonna be a big hit when you have
kids in the movie they are constantly
growing so my question is if this is a
big hit is it one of these things where
you know you guys would be amped to just
jump right back in because you know jack
and and everybody or they're gonna in
like a year they're gonna look a lot
different
yeah there's Actos today exactly know we
gotta move we got to move swiftly with a
sequel for sure right I have to ask you
an individual question I am very excited
about James Gunn making a DC movie and a
lot of people are saying it's called The
Suicide Squad is that definitely the
title those it is it is currently the
title yes
Suicide Squad and I heard that you said
it well I've heard it's a reboot and
you've confirmed it's a reboot does that
how does that work with the last film as
it just sort of this never happened or
can't really go into it now but it all
will be revealed in due course at all I
might tell you off camera - sure so of
my last thing for you I'm always curious
about the editing process because
ultimately that's the final rewrite can
you talk a little bit about an last
question how that move maybe how the
movie maybe changed in the editing room
maybe what you learned from any early
screenings it didn't change dramatically
I mean this structure was always this
it just you know it's a big puzzle piece
we're in the edit and sometimes you find
like oh these pieces actually might need
something to put in there but it's kind
of cool when you have a movie like this
where you have you know scans of every
environment scan so that reactor so if
it's a little action piece that you need
just to fit two pieces together you can
kind of create that in post a lot of
times which is really cool
you